Hey, well good morning. Hi. Oh, did I wake you? No, no, no. I was just in the middle of not well, I can tell you what you weren't in the middle of combing your hair. Did my hair look messy? Well, look at the back. Oh, yeah, it's kind of sticking up. What's morning time and I haven't gone through my routine. So you just literally rolled out of bed and sat in front of the mic. Yeah, is that okay? Do you sleep next to the mic? I sleep in the booth. Yeah. All right. What's the name of the show we're doing today? Oh, we're doing Smartless now. Yeah, right now. We'll go to the smart list. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Oh, I got to read this. Wait, well I got to read this text that Jason sent me the other day. Oh, okay, so I was just I'm back from Chicago,
嘿，早安。嗨。噢，我是不是吵醒你了？没有，没有，没有。我刚才正在……好吧，我可以告诉你你刚才绝对没在梳头。我的头发看起来很乱吗？嗯，看看后面。噢，对，有点翘起来了。现在是早上，我还没开始我的日常流程。所以你真的是刚从床上爬起来就坐在麦克风前了。对，这样可以吗？你睡在麦克风旁边吗？我在录音棚里睡。好吧。我们今天要录的节目叫什么名字？哦，我们现在在录Smartless。对，就是现在。我们要去smart list。Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. 哦，我得读这个。等等，我得读一下杰森前几天发给我的短信。噢，好吧，我刚从芝加哥回来，
So when I was in Chicago, I'm staying at this hotel and I put my slippers on that they provide inside the hotel room and I took a shot of my feet in the slippers and I said to Jason, hey, dumb shit, is this how you do it? Right? Cause he doesn't want us, you know, he has a fear of step walking around hotel rooms.
所以当我在芝加哥时，我住在一家酒店里，我穿上了酒店房间里提供的拖鞋，我拍了一张我穿着拖鞋的脚的照片，然后我对杰森说，嘿，笨蛋，你是这么做的吗？对吧？因为他不想让我们，你知道的，他对在酒店房间里走来走去有一种恐惧。
Not a fear, just a practicality. Just a practicality, he doesn't want to walk barefoot on hotel. In the same way I wear shoes on the subway, you know? Okay. It's a little different. There's a lot of traffic in a hotel. Quick side bar, quick side bar.
不是恐惧，只是一种实用主义。只是实用主义，他不想在酒店里光脚走路。就像我坐地铁时穿鞋一样，你知道吗？好吧。这有点不同。酒店里人流量很大。快速插话，快速插话。
Last time we were on the subway. Yeah. I mean, you know. Okay. We got an answer. Thanks very much. Thanks for calling, calling. So I said, so I texted Michael, I took a picture of it
我们上次坐地铁。那是。我的意思是，你知道的。好吧。我们得到了回答。非常感谢。谢谢你们打电话来。所以我说，我给迈克尔发了短信，我拍了一张照片
and in the background of the picture is my tennis shoe with the little orthotic lift in it. Cause I'm wearing that. Quick side bar. Last time you played tennis. Yeah. You can call them sneakers. Okay.
照片的背景是我的网球鞋，鞋里还带着一个小矫形垫。因为我穿着那个。快速插话。你上次打网球。对。你可以叫它们运动鞋。好吧。
Okay. So in the photo, in the background is my shoe with the little orthotic lift in it, like an old man. So I go, did I get this? Listener, let's be clear. This is a pad that he straps on to the bottom of whatever shoe he's wearing so that he can match the height of his unnecessary walking boot that he's wearing
好吧。所以在照片里，背景是我的鞋子，鞋里塞着一个小矫形垫，就像个老人一样。所以我说，我买对了吗？听众朋友，我们要说清楚。这是一个他绑在自己穿的任何鞋子底下的垫子，这样他就可以配合他那只不必要的、正在穿着的步行靴的高度
cause he's got an injured little piggy. That's right. That's right. One small toe that just hurts a little. So in the photo is the slippers. And I say, hey dumb shit, did I get this right? Like kind of making fun of him, but not really. So then he goes, you did get the slipper part right,
因为他有一只受伤的小猪蹄。没错。没错。只有一个小脚趾稍微有点疼。所以在照片里是拖鞋。然后我说，嘿，笨蛋，我没弄错吧？有点像在取笑他，但又不是真的。然后他说，拖鞋部分你确实弄对了，
but this is still very, very wrong. And I go, that's my shoe. Are you jealous? And he goes, no, I know. I'm talking about the friggin orthopedic riser on it. And I said, I know that's because of my fucking boot on the other foot. The one I'm going to ram up your blown out asshole.
但这还是非常非常错的。然后我说，那是我的鞋。你在嫉妒吗？他说，不，我知道。我说的是上面那个该死的矫形垫高器。我说，我知道，那是因为我另一只脚上该死的靴子。就是我要塞进你那烂菊花里的那只。
Right. And he wrote, I know I'm saying enough, chop the toe off or develop a terrible limp. It will not be worse than the cruise ship medical wear. Well, I was hot that night. The cruise ship medical wear. You're still wearing a walking boot unnecessarily. And this one.
对。他写道，我知道，我的意思是够了，把脚趾切掉或者变成一个可怕的跛子。这也不会比游轮医疗靴更糟。好吧，那天我很火大。游轮医疗靴。你还在不必要地穿着步行靴。还有这个。
You're sitting. And that. You're sitting. Come on, Sean. Sean, by the way, who said they went on a hike recently? Was Sean anywhere the boot? Who was it who you went on a hike with recently? But Sean, seriously, do we have an ETA,
你坐着。还有那个。你坐着。得了吧，肖恩。肖恩，顺便问一下，谁说他们最近去徒步旅行了？肖恩穿靴子了吗？你最近跟谁一起去徒步旅行了？但肖恩，说真的，我们有没有预计到达时间，
any sort of prognosis as to when you can stop the nonsense? Does the doctor say you're just stuck with this the rest of your life? No, no, no, no, like three months. But I don't care. What do I care? What do I look like? I mean, that's like, I get that.
或者关于你什么时候能停止这种无稽之谈的任何预测？医生说你这辈子就得这样了吗？不，不，不，不，大概三个月。但我不在乎。我有什么在乎的？我看起来像什么？我的意思是，那就像，我懂。
Again, one more time on the injury. What exactly? What is it? It's a little tiny tear on my second toe underneath it. All right. So you have the whole boot. Yeah. You ever seen pictures of guys hitting the beach at Normandy?
再说一次，关于那个伤。到底是什么？到底是什么？我第二根脚趾下面有一个很小的撕裂。好吧。所以你整只脚都穿上了靴子。对。你见过诺曼底登陆士兵的照片吗？
That's me. None of them had a boot. Yeah. So here's the deal. So our guest is somebody that we've all known for a long time and we all have adored for a long time. Andy Richter. It's not Andy Richter.
那就是我。他们谁都没穿靴子。对。所以情况是这样的：我们的嘉宾是我们大家认识很久、也喜爱了很久的人。安迪·里查特。不是安迪·里查特。
And we love him more than we love Andy. And if Andy's listening, he knows that that's okay. He's a guy who started, he didn't start, when he graduated from UCLA, he didn't immediately go into comedy. Chase Utley. He went into not Chase Utley. Fuck Jesus.
我们爱他胜过爱安迪。如果安迪在听，他知道这没关系。他是一个起步于……他不是起步于……当他从UCLA毕业时，他并没有马上进入喜剧界。蔡斯·阿特利。他进入的不是蔡斯·阿特利。操，耶稣。
We're not doing the guessing game the whole time. He went into finance originally. Then he started going to Groundlings and he started performing and writing. Then he got a couple of great writing jobs. He started writing on that 70s show, Third Rock from the Sun. He then submitted and ended up writing on Letterman.
我们不能一整直玩猜谜游戏。他最初进入的是金融界。然后他开始去接地剧团（Groundlings），开始表演和写作。接着他得到了一些很棒的编剧工作。他开始为《那七十年代秀》和《歪星撞地球》写剧本。然后他投稿并最终成为了《大卫·莱特曼深夜秀》的编剧。
Spike Ferreston. He wrote on Letterman, Wally's brother, Spike, no. He wrote on Letterman. Then he left that, he went back to LA and then Lauren Michaels saw him performing, asked him to audition for SNL. He was already a writer on many comedies and he said yes and thank God he did
斯派克·费雷斯顿。他为莱特曼写过剧本，沃利的兄弟，斯派克，不对。他为莱特曼写过剧本。然后他离开了那里，回到了洛杉矶，接着洛恩·麦克尔斯看到他的表演，邀请他去为《周六夜现场》试镜。他当时已经是许多喜剧的编剧了，他答应了，谢天谢地他去了，
because he's brought us so many great characters over the years, not the least of which one, there was a recurring character that he then ended up making a movie out of it. He's now making a series out of it. It's our friend, Will Forte. Oh, Will Forte. Oh, Will.
因为这些年来他给我们带来了那么多伟大的角色，其中有一个反复出现的角色，他最后甚至把它拍成了电影。他现在正在把它拍成电视剧。他是我们的朋友，威尔·福特。噢，威尔·福特。噢，威尔。
Ike and Huber. Yes. Hello. Hello. Hi, Will. Look at this, more comedic royalty than smartness. I know, look at it. Look at Will Forte.
艾克和休伯。对。你好。你好。嗨，威尔。瞧瞧这个，比聪明人还要多的喜剧界皇室成员。我知道，你看。看看威尔·福特。
Will, one of my favorite things about Will is he used to, his outgoing voicemail message, used to be Will, and I think John Solomon's singing, Will Forte, beep, and then went into the beep, that was it. Is that right, Will? Who was it? It was my ex-girlfriend, Amy Keen.
威尔，我最喜欢威尔的一点是，他过去，他过去的语音信箱留言是威尔，我想还有约翰·索洛蒙在唱，威尔·福特，哔——然后就进了哔——声，就那样。是这样吗，威尔？那是谁？那是我的前女友，艾米·基恩。
She sounds a lot like John Solomon. Yes. Yes. So Forte, I meant to, when I say we've all known and loved you for a long time. Everybody I know who knows you feels the same way, has great affection for you. You're one of the warmest, kindest, sweetest guys
她听起来很像约翰·索洛蒙。是的。是的。所以福特，我想说的是，当我们说我们大家认识并喜爱你很久了。我认识的每一个了解你的人都有同感，都对你满怀喜爱。你是这个行业里最热情、
in this business and you offset people like Bateman, which is nice. So would you, no, there's no bud, that was the bird. That was, because it hasn't been unanimous from what I'm understanding from the people I talk to. Wow, yeah, but you keep going. You're talking to nicer people. Go ahead.
最善良、最可爱的人之一，你平衡了像贝特曼这样的人，这很好。所以你会，不，没有“但是”，那是鸟叫。那是，因为根据我从我交谈过的人那里了解到的情况，这并不是全票通过。哇，是的，但你继续说。你在和更好的人聊天。请继续。
It's so, no, I know it. Will knows who they are. Wait, you've got to listen. You know who the exact people are who don't like you. Yeah, I got to, you know. Let's hear a couple of them. It's like Sean Spicer is your fan and Jim Shorting. Jim Shorting, honestly, can you,
太……不，我知道。威尔知道他们是谁。等等，你得听着。你知道那些不喜欢你的人到底是谁。 yeah，我得，你知道的。听几个名字吧。就像肖恩·斯派塞是你的粉丝，还有吉姆·肖丁。吉姆·肖丁，老实说，你能，
and let's go around the room here and I'll start. I'm pretty proud to say there is not a person on the globe where I feel like I got, if I see them coming down the street, I'd cross to the other side of the street, like that I just don't get along with that person. We've got a lot of baggage. It's going to be a nightmare if they make eye contact with me. I don't have any enemies, I guess is what I'm saying.
我们在这个房间里转一圈，我先来。我很自豪地说，在这个世界上没有这样一个人：如果我看到他迎面走来，我会走到马路对面去，就好像我和那个人合不来一样。我们有很多过节。如果他们和我对视，那将是一场噩梦。我想我是没有什么敌人吧。
Do you guys, will or not? You're saying that because you know I do. Well, I just, I'm just curious. I don't think, I don't think I do. I'm trying to think, I don't think that I have any. No, I don't think you do. I mean, I, no, I don't think you do. Sean, Sean, do you know?
你们呢，威尔，还是没有？你这么说是因为你知道我有。好吧，我只是，我只是好奇。我不认为，我不认为我有。我在努力回想，我不认为我有任何敌人。不，我想你没有。我是说，不，我想你没有。肖恩，肖恩，你知道吗？
No, I have no enemies, no. Forte. Forte? I certainly wouldn't cross the street because of anybody. You know, I'm trying to be better about just confronting issues when they come up, life's about getting better. And I think I, for a long time, I was, I don't know,
不，我没有敌人，没有。福特？我当然不会因为任何人而过马路。你知道，当问题出现时，我试着更好地去面对它们，生活就是关于变得更好。我想我，很长一段时间以来，我，不知道，
just, just scared about stuff, try to avoid it, but trying to be better. But you know, yeah, there's certainly people who, I don't know, bad breakups or something, which might be an awkward situation, but. Did you used to be the kind of person growing up where you did keep it all inside and you were like, oh, I can't, I gotta keep good face.
只是，只是对事情感到害怕，试着去逃避，但我在努力做得更好。但你知道，是的，肯定有些人，我不知道，糟糕的分手或者别的什么，可能会导致尴尬的局面，但是。你在成长过程中是不是那种把所有事情都藏在心里的人，你会觉得，哦，我不能，我得保持好脸色。
And I can't, and then it just bursts out like craziness. Oh yeah. No, I would, I would, oh sure, I'd keep stuff in. You know, I wanted, all situations have a nice little tidy bow on it. Kilauea, Kilauea used to be your, your handle in high school, I under said, right? Yes. Yeah, yeah, quite the volcano.
而且我不能，然后它就像发疯一样突然爆发出来。哦，是的。不，我会，我会，噢当然，我会把事情憋在心里。你知道的，我希望，所有的局势都能有一个漂亮的小蝴蝶结。基拉韦亚，基拉韦亚过去是你在高中的代号，我听说过，对吧？是的。对，对，真是一座火山。
Well, actually, Forte, you bring up an interesting point. You do like to wrap things up. And this is something I've always admired. Will, you're often the last person to leave a party. Yeah. Right, is that a fair assessment? He loves to clean. Well, he, no, but he cleans up relationships.
嗯，事实上，福特，你提出了一个有趣的观点。你确实喜欢把事情做个了结。这是我一直很佩服的一点。威尔，你通常是最后一个离开派对的人。对，对吧，这个评价公平吗？他喜欢打扫卫生。嗯，他，不，但他是去“打扫”人际关系。
Like he talks to everybody. He says goodbye to everybody properly. You never do what they call an Irish goodbye. You never slip out. You go, and especially if you've been talking to somebody, you make a point, which is really nice. I contact and you say, great talking to you. I'll see you later.
就像他跟每个人都说话。他跟每个人都好好道别。你绝不会做他们所说的“爱尔兰式道别”（悄悄溜走）。你从不溜走。你会，特别是如果你刚才一直在跟某人聊天，你会特意这么做，这真的很棒。眼神接触，然后你说，很高兴跟你聊天。回头见。
I have to go. Like you say all that stuff. Mostly people would be like, all right, I gotta go later. You know. Yeah, exactly. If I was the host of party that would put up a flare for me. I'd be like, okay, this guy clearly broke something really expensive in some of the rooms.
我得走了。就像你会说所有这些话。大多数人会觉得，好吧，我得走了，回头见。你知道的。对，绝对的。如果我是派对的主办方，这会为我亮起信号弹。我会觉得，好吧，这家伙显然在某间屋子里弄坏了什么非常昂贵的东西。
You know what, Jason? The first time I noticed it was one time we had, there were a bunch of people at your old house and you're in Amanda's house. And I remember Forte was there. Sean, I think you were there too. And you guys had like a party or something. And I think I was staying with you and Amanda.
你知道吗，杰森？我第一次注意到这一点是，有一次我们，你老房子里有一群人，在阿曼达的房子里。我记得福特也在。肖恩，我想你也在。你们举办了一个派对什么的。我想我当时住在你和阿曼达那里。
And Forte was by far the last person to leave. You literally said goodbye to everybody. You know it's so funny too, because I think people think it's cool to like stand in a corner and not connect with people or leave early. Like you said, well, I think the cool thing is to stay and be the last person and be gracious and extend yourself and talk to everybody.
而福特绝对是最后一个离开的人。你真的是跟每个人都道别了。你知道这也很搞笑，因为我觉得人们以为站在角落里不与人交流或者早退是很酷的事。就像你说的，威尔，我觉得酷的事是留下来，做最后一个人，表现得大方，展现自我，跟每个人都交谈。
And right, I think that's the cool thing to do. Yeah, and that's sort of my point. Will you always make time for people? You always have conversations that are engaged. You're not flitting around. Like you engage with people. That's important to you, right? Yes, I mean, sometimes I feel like
对吧，我觉得这才是酷的事。是的，这正是我的意思。威尔，你总是为人们腾出时间。你总是有投入的对话。你不会四处飘忽。你会与人互动。这对你很重要，对吧？是的，我的意思是，有时我觉得
I've gotten worse and worse at it. I think I would do exactly what you're saying all the time. Now having a baby makes it easier to not feel bad if I have to leave early. There are just times you just have to get out at a moment's notice. And yeah, it was almost an illness, how I said goodbye to people at parties.
我在这方面变得越来越糟了。我想我以前会一直做你刚才说的那种事。现在有了孩子，如果我必须早退，就不会觉得那么内疚了。有时候你就是得在接到通知的瞬间就离开。是的，我在派对上跟人道别的方式简直像是一种病。
It was like, you know, I'd start saying rounds. Oh, I didn't say bye to this person. They're gonna freaking hate my guts the next time I see them if they noticed that I've left without saying goodbye. And then... Now you're not getting invited to parties because of it. They're like, oh, no, no, no, no, no. You invite Forte.
就像是，你知道的，我会开始一轮又一轮地道别。哦，我还没跟这个人道别呢。如果他们发现我没有道别就走了，下次见面时他们一定会恨死我的。然后……现在你因为这个而收不到派对邀请了。他们会想，哦，不，不，不，不，不。你邀请了福特。
He's gonna stay all night shaking your hand and helping you clean up and yeah. And then I do a second round. It's like, it was so long that I had to you say goodbye to people. It was almost like a new party. It was not. Haven't left yet.
他会待上一整晚，跟你握手，帮着你打扫卫生，然后……接着我开始第二轮道别。这就像是，道别的时间太长了，你不得不跟人们重新道别。这几乎成了一个新的派对。并不是。还没离开呢。
When we were doing Brother Solomon, which we can get into in a second. Hold for a plus. When we were, yeah, hold for a plus. You're gonna be holding a long time. Yeah, I love that movie. I will say it every time. I know.
当我们制作《所罗门兄弟》时，我们一会儿可以聊这个。请稍等。当我们，是的，请稍等。你要等很长时间。是的，我很喜欢那部电影。我每次都会这么说。我知道。
And you were the first and biggest fan of that movie, Jason. So we were shooting Brother Solomon. And I remember one day I was like, Forte was always like grabbing, making sure, or he'd leave me notes on my car in anagrams, like really long, right? So, and he's remember for a while, you were speaking in anagrams. Oh, yes.
你是那部电影的第一个也是最大的粉丝，杰森。所以我们在拍摄《所罗门兄弟》。我记得有一天，我觉得，福特总是抓着不放，或者他会在我的车上留下用变位词写的便条，真的很长，对吧？所以，而且他，你记得有一段时间，你一直在用变位词说话吗？哦，是的。
Oh, wow. That was a long time ago. That was a long time. It was like 15 years ago. And Forte would go, I-W-T-T-Y-L-W-Y-G-B. And I'd be like, when you go, I'll talk to you later when you get back, right? Just for a while, for a couple of months,
噢，哇。那是很久以前的事了。那是很久以前了。大概是15年前。福特会说，I-W-T-T-Y-L-W-Y-G-B。我会说，当你走的时候，等你回来我再跟你聊，对吧？有一段时间，持续了几个月，
hoping to catch on. For a while he was talking like that. So anyway, those are acronyms, right? Acronyms, not anagrams? No, that's not anagrams. Yeah, that's an acronym. Sorry, that's an acronym. That's an acronym.
希望能听懂。有一段时间他就是这么说话的。不管怎样，那些是首字母缩略词，对吧？首字母缩略词，而不是变位词？不，那不是变位词。对，那是首字母缩略词。抱歉，那是首字母缩略词。那是首字母缩略词。
That's right, sorry. Googling anagrams? I am sorry to call you out on that, but I- No, no, no, I'm glad you did. You're absolutely right. I said anagram, right? Yeah, it's an acronym. Sorry.
没错，抱歉。在谷歌上搜变位词？我很抱歉指出这一点，但我——不，不，不，我很高兴你指出来了。你完全正确。我说的是变位词，对吧？对，是首字母缩略词。抱歉。
Wait, well, didn't you have like a kind of an openly about it, and we can cut any of this if you don't want, didn't you openly talk about having OCD? And was that one of the OCD kind of things that you would do, something like that? That didn't fit under OCD. That was just a weird thing that I just liked doing. That was just a party favor.
等等，威尔，你是不是曾经有过一种，呃，算是公开谈论过，如果你不想说我们可以剪掉任何部分，你是不是公开谈过自己有强迫症（OCD）？那是不是你会做的那种强迫症行为之一，类似于那样的东西？那不属于强迫症。那只是我喜欢做的一件怪事。那只是个派对小彩蛋。
I mean, certainly it got stuck in, I just got stuck in that gear for a while. And it just like my brain would naturally, instead of hearing, hey, it was great saying you, I'd go, H-I-W-G-S-Y. And I got pretty fast at it. He got really fast. He was still kind of there.
我的意思是，当然它卡在了，我只是在那档档口卡了一段时间。它就像我的脑子会自然而然地，与其听到“嘿，很高兴跟你聊天”，我会说：“H-I-W-G-S-Y”。而且我在这方面变得挺快的。他真的变得很快。他当时差不多就是这样。
That was great. That was really good. And I think it sort of tickled something in your comedy brain. And once it was active, like you couldn't turn it off. But anyway, my point is, so I remember thinking like, I fuck Forte, we're shooting downtown. I'm like, I'm not gonna let him say goodbye to me.
太棒了。那真的很好。而且我觉得这触动了你喜剧大脑里的某种东西。一旦它被激活，就像你关不掉它一样。总之，我的意思是，所以我记得当时想，操，福特，我们在市中心拍戏。我想，我可不让他跟我道别。
So I got in my car and I drove like 30 yards away. And we ran, I run out when they wrapped, I ran out, got in my car, 30 yards away. And Forte came back to the trailers and he's kind of looking around. And from 30 yards away, I honked, and he looks up the street and I went, and I just drove away like you got the win.
所以我上了车，把车开到了大概30码外的地方。等他们收工时，我跑了出去，跑上车，停在30码外。福特回到房车那边，他四处张望。从30码外，我按了喇叭，他抬头朝街上看去，我说，然后我直接开走了，就像你赢了一样。
And I'm like, I'm not gonna let, what a dick. Hey, Will, I think I'd be remiss. I wanna, I know you're probably sick of talking about it, but I think my sister Tracy and a lot of viewers are kind of fascinated with origin stories of a phenomenal SNL alum like yourself. And what the process was about getting the show and how did it come about?
我就想，我才不让，真是个混蛋。嘿，威尔，我想我若是不说这些就太失职了。我想，我知道你可能已经厌烦谈论这个了，但我认为我的姐姐特雷西以及许多观众都对像你这样出色的SNL校友的成名史着迷。当时加入这个节目过程是怎样的？它是怎么促成的？
Because you are one of the best, most legendary people to come out of there. You had the best characters, you were always, always so funny in every sketch you did. And so what was that like? I know, again, boring question for you, but really exciting for me. So what is, so how did you get the,
因为你是从那里走出来的最优秀、最传奇的人之一。你拥有最棒的角色，在你的每一部小品里，你总是，总是那么搞笑。所以那段经历是怎样的？我知道，再次声明，这对你来说是个无聊的问题，但对我来说却超级兴奋。所以，你是怎么得到的？
like how did you get the role? What was the process like? What were you doing at the time? Yeah, what was your situation? Okay, so I was writing at that 70s show. Oh, that's right, which is crazy. My, I had been writing for like four or five years and had been on a ton of different shows
就像你是怎么得到这个角色的？整个过程是怎样的？你当时在做什么？是的，你当时的情况是怎样的？好吧，所以当时我在《那七十年代秀》当编剧。噢，对，太疯狂了。我，我写了大概四五年剧本，曾在无数不同的节目里待过，
that kept just getting booted after 13 episodes. Well, sorry, sorry to stop you and even go further back. How did you start writing on comedy series? Like what was, you graduate UCLA, then how did you start writing on a comedy, on a big network comedy? Okay, so I, you mentioned as you were introducing me that my dad was in the financial industry.
那些节目拍了13集之后就不断被砍。好吧，抱歉，抱歉打断你，甚至还要往前追溯。你是怎么开始为喜剧系列写剧本的？比如，你是怎么，你从UCLA毕业，然后你是怎么开始为喜剧，为大型电视网喜剧写剧本的？好吧，所以我，你刚才在介绍我时提到我父亲在金融界工作。
So I just jumped into that. I thought, oh, I'm gonna try to, you know, sell stocks and bonds and I just, I hated it. It was, everyone was really nice, but it just was, Can't see why it seems really fun. Yeah, super fun. Super fun. It's really interesting.
所以我一头扎了进去。我想，哦，我要去试试，你知道的，卖股票和债券，但我讨厌它。每个人都很好，但它只是，看不出有什么好玩的，因为看起来真的很有趣。对，超级有趣。超级有趣。这真的很有趣。
The danger and the intrigue. The people are incredible. The danger. The people in the financial sector are so interesting. Go ahead. By the way, my dad is in the financial industry. Will. No, I know, I have a lot of friends
其中的危险和阴谋。人们太不可思议了。危险。金融界的人太有趣了。请继续。顺便说一下，我父亲就在金融行业。威尔。不，我知道，我有很多朋友
in the financial industry and they all know your dad and they say your dad's really interesting. Oh, so you weren't being sarcastic. No, of course not. I'm sorry, I read that as sarcasm and I was, folks, I've met are fascinating. Let's make the record clear. Yes.
在金融行业，他们都认识你父亲，他们说你父亲真的很有趣。噢，所以你刚才不是在讽刺。不，当然不是。抱歉，我把那当成讽刺了，我当时——各位，我遇到的人都很迷人。让我们把话说清楚。是的。
Okay. Okay. Me too. No, I mean, no, let me just say Dan D's is the most interesting man in finance. Go ahead. The most. The most. Okay. Okay. So go ahead, Will.
好吧。好吧。我也是。不，我是说，不，让我直说吧，Dan D's（丹·迪斯/谐音：这些坚果）是金融界最有趣的男人。请继续。最有趣的。最有趣的。好吧。好吧。所以请继续，威尔。
So you're working finance. There's some kind of D's nuts joke in there, but I can't. Dan D's nuts. Oh God, that's right. Okay. I know. How about how interesting D's nuts are?
所以你在金融界工作。这里面肯定有什么关于“D's nuts”（这些蛋/坚果）的笑话，但我抓不住。Dan D's nuts。哦天哪，没错。好吧。我知道。D's nuts有多有趣？
Something like that. I'll work on it. Keep going. Keep going. Or hey, Dan D's nuts, right? I mean, there's just, there's that. Let's workshop it right after this short podcast. So Will, so there you are.
诸如此类。我再琢磨琢磨。继续。继续。或者，嘿，Dan D's nuts，对吧？我的意思是，就是有这个。我们在录完这个简短的播客后就一起头脑风暴一下。所以威尔，你就在那儿。
So there you are. There I am. You're in finance business. Looking at numbers, ingesting numbers, crunching numbers. You're standing in front of a mirror naked and you're like, what do you want to do with your life, Will? I just couldn't. Why are you aroused?
所以你就在那儿。我就在那儿。你在金融行业。看着数字，吸收数字，处理数字。你光着身子站在镜子前，心想：威尔，你到底想用你的人生做什么？我就是办不到。你为什么兴奋？
Yeah. And then, and so I, I just, I don't know. I don't even know at what point in my life I realized I wanted to do comedy, but it must have been years before I was, you know, everyone loves movies, everyone loves TV shows, but I particularly loved SNL obviously and, and Letterman. So, so years down the road.
是的。然后，所以我就，我不知道。我甚至不记得人生中是在哪个时间点意识到我想做喜剧的，但那一定是在我，你知道的，每个人都喜欢电影，每个人都喜欢电视节目，但我尤其喜欢SNL，当然还有莱特曼。所以，那是多年以后的事了。
And you knew that you weren't unfunny based on school and whatnot, you're making kids laugh. You knew, you knew you had a sense of humor, but you want, how did you channel that into writing? How'd you get an opportunity to do it? Yeah, cause it's a big jump from finance into being a comedy writer. Well, I first started out like,
你知道自己并不是不好笑，根据在学校的经历什么的，你逗笑了孩子们。你知道，你知道自己有幽默感，但你想，你是如何把这一点转化成写作的？你是怎么得到这个机会的？是的，因为从金融界跨界成为喜剧编剧是一个巨大的跨越。好吧，我最初开始时，
oh, the easiest way where I don't have to put myself out there is too much is to just start writing stuff. So I just started writing with this partner, Ann Blenden, was my, my writing partner back then and now Ann Hutchinson. We're doing a lot of applause tonight. And it was just such a great release too for this hellish job. And then I'd start, I don't know,
哦，最简单的方法，让我不用过分展露自己，就是开始写东西。所以我开始和一个搭档安·布伦登（Ann Blenden）一起写，她是我当时的写作搭档，现在是安·哈钦森（Ann Hutchinson）。我们今晚得到了很多掌声。这也是对这份地狱般工作的一种极好的宣泄。然后我开始，我不知道，
I started realizing, oh, I think I'd love to try to act out the stuff that I write. So somebody told me about the groundlings. My friend Scott Thomas, I think was the first person who told me about the groundlings. And I went and checked it out. And the very first Sunday show I went to, which is the Sunday show, the newer people,
我开始意识到，哦，我想我愿意尝试把我写的东西表演出来。所以有人跟我提起接地剧团（Groundlings）。我的朋友斯科特·托马斯（Scott Thomas），我想他是第一个跟我提起接地剧团的人。我去看了看。我去的第一个周日秀，也就是周日秀，是那些比较新的人演的，
it's like you work your way through the groundling system, make your way into the Sunday show, if you, if you climb the ladder and the Sunday show is like the minor leagues. And then from the Sunday show, you make it into the main company. And the Sunday show that I saw right before I took my first groundlings class was Will Ferrell,
就像你在接地剧团的体系里一步步往上爬，如果你能一路晋升，就能进入周日秀。周日秀就像是小联盟。然后从周日秀，你才能进入主剧团。我在上第一节接地剧团课之前看的那个周日秀，里面有威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）、
Chris Kattan and a gas dire. I think, no, Parnell was not, no, Parnell. Yeah, Parnell. Yeah, that makes sense. It was, it was just this amazing group of people that I had no idea, oh, this is gonna be like the future of comedy. Yeah, that's insane.
克里斯·卡坦（Chris Kattan）和加斯·戴尔（Gas Dyer）。我想，不对，帕内尔（Parnell）不在，不对，帕内尔。对，帕内尔。对，这说得通。那是，那是一群不可思议的人，我当时完全不知道，噢，这将是喜剧的未来。是的，太疯狂了。
You just started seeing this really funny show. And I said, oh, this is, this looks like fun. And they were probably hilarious. Oh, they were amazing. Yeah, of course. And there were a ton of other amazing people. That's the craziest thing about that. Like along the way, you go through the whole groundlings.
你只是开始看到这个非常有趣的演出。我说，哦，这看起来很好玩。他们大概滑稽极了。噢，他们太惊艳了。是的，当然。还有一大批其他了不起的人。这才是其中最疯狂的地方。一路走来，你经历整个接地剧团的过程。
Some of the funniest people didn't make it. You know, it's, it's just, there's such a luck element to it as well. Yeah. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So then there at the groundlings, there's some sort of a scout perhaps from 70 show
有些最搞笑的人也没能成功。你知道的，这其中也有很大的运气成分。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。所以在接地剧团里，可能有什么来自《七十年代秀》的星探，
or some sort of. Yeah, how'd you get that packet in there? No, as I was doing groundlings, I was still trying to write stuff. I met Matt Rice is my agent. He was, he had taken me on that. Love, love. He's a friend of the show.
或者某种。是的，你是怎么把你的剧本投进去的？不，我在接地剧团的时候，我还在尝试写东西。我遇到了马特·赖伊斯（Matt Rice），他是我的经纪人。他把我签下来了——爱，爱他。他是节目的朋友。
Matt Rice is a friend. Yeah. So I went to UCLA with him and dated one of his very good friends, Amanda Glazer. Right. And so met him. Do you cross the street when you see Amanda Glazer? No.
马特·赖伊斯是我们的朋友。是的。我和他是UCLA的校友，我还和他的一个好朋友阿曼达·格雷泽（Amanda Glazer）约会过。对。所以就认识他了。你看到阿曼达·格雷泽时会过马路吗？不。
No, no, no, no. For sure. No, no, no. I think we're on good terms at least. Yeah, no, no, no. We haven't talked in a long time. She'll reach out to you after this, for sure. Yeah.
不，不，不，不。当然不会。不，不，不。我想我们至少关系不错。对，不，不，不。我们已经很久没说话了。她看完这个一定会联系你的，肯定的。是的。
But I think fondly of her and hopefully- Check your voicemail. Yeah. So anyway, we had known each other through Amanda. And also we were in fraternities. I was a fraternity guy and he was a fraternity guy. We'll double back to that. And yeah, so we were right next to each other.
但我对她满怀深情，希望——去查查你的语音信箱吧。是的。总之，我们通过阿曼达互相认识了。而且我们都在兄弟会里。我是个兄弟会成员，他也是个兄弟会成员。我们回头再聊这个。对，所以我们俩挨得很近。
Really correct. Just go back to the groundlings. We have a mutual friend, Carrie Aisley, and she was telling me this one thing that used to do where there was a sketch where it was a spelling bee and you just spelled a word and didn't stop for like 10 minutes and just picked random letters and it went on and on and on.
说得对。回到接地剧团。我们有一个共同的朋友凯莉·艾斯利（Carrie Aisley），她曾跟我提起过你以前做过的一件事，有一个小品是拼字比赛，你只是拼一个单词，然后连续10分钟停不下来，只是随机挑选字母，没完没了地进行下去。
Yes. Yeah. It was actually, they'd let me do it. It's a SNL finally. Oh, they did. I put it up like five times and finally, I think just to shut me up and not have me put it up at the table again.
是的。对。事实上，他们最终让我把它搬上了SNL。哦，他们真的上了。我把它提交了五次，最后，大概只是为了让我闭嘴，别再把它拿到剧本会议上讨论了。
Did it make the cut? Did it make the show? It made the show. It turned out doing really well. Can I just say in the middle of this is a sideline. This is on this topic of finally, we'll put it up five times. During the writer strike in the end of 2007, early 2008,
它通过审核了吗？它上节目了吗？它上节目了。结果效果非常好。我可以在这中间插一句闲话吗？就是关于“终于把它提交了五次”这个话题。在2007年底到2008年初的编剧大罢工期间，
they did a show, a live SNL at UCB, at the old theater on 26th Street. And because there was no, they weren't airing any shows. So they did a live SNL, not for broadcast. Mike Sarah was the host. And basically they just picked sketches that had never made it to air that were like favorites of the cast and the writers and everybody,
他们在UCB（UCB剧院）的26街老剧场做了一场现场版的SNL。因为当时没有，他们没有播任何节目。所以他们做了一场现场版的SNL，不是为了广播播出的。迈克·塞拉（Mike Cera）是主持人。基本上他们只是挑选了那些从未播出口碑极佳的小品，这些都是演员、编剧和所有人的最爱，
but that had never been picked. And I don't know, there were probably eight or nine sketches. And if there were nine sketches, eight of them were forte sketches that were all cast and writer favorites. Cause they were so insane, but couldn't make it onto the air because the subject matter was too hot or whatever. Or they thought they were too esoteric.
但以前从未被选中。我不知道，大概有八九个小品。如果有九个小品的话，其中八个都是福特的，全都是演员和编剧的最爱。因为它们太疯狂了，但由于题材太敏感或者别的什么原因而无法播出。或者他们觉得太深奥了。
Or by the way, just too funny. Just too funny. It was an unbelievably hilarious show, Will. That was, I mean, all time. That was a fun night. That was an incredible night. Anyway, sorry. I'd love to see that.
或者顺便说一句，只是太搞笑了。只是太搞笑了。那是一场令人难以置信的爆笑演出，威尔。那真是，我的意思是，史上最佳。那是个好玩的夜晚。那是个不可思议的夜晚。不管怎样，抱歉。我很想看看那个。
So Will Forte, with all of this comedic brilliance, and you don't have to agree with it, just plug your ears. Do you feel like, where does it all, what's your outlet for all that stuff? Cause you've got more in your brain than opportunity could possibly satisfy. So where is it going all? Where do you like to point it?
所以威尔·福特，凭借你所有的喜剧才华——你不需要承认这一点，捂上耳朵就行了。你觉得，这一切都源自哪里？你所有这些东西的宣泄口是什么？因为你脑子里装的东西远超机遇所能满足的极限。所以这一切都去哪儿了？你喜欢把它指向哪里？
The smart list podcast. Yeah, good answer. Next question. Yeah, number two. Wait, wait, wait. So Will, I do want to get back to, sorry. We, and we've taken so many tangents here, but so you're doing this, you're doing the groundlings,
Smartless播客。是的，好答案。下一个问题。好的，第二个。等等，等等，等等。所以威尔，我确实想回到，抱歉。我们，我们在这里扯了太多题外话了，所以你在做这个，你在做接地剧团，
whatever you have a friend, you've got to pack it. You send it to what? You just send it to Carsey Warner, care of Radford studios. I had done these weird cartoons. So I did these weird cartoons, showed them to Matt Rice. That was what made him say,
不管怎样你有个朋友，你得弄个剧本包。你把它寄给谁？你只是寄给卡西·沃纳（Carsey Warner）公司，转交给拉德福德工作室（Radford studios）吗？我当时做过这些奇怪的动画片。我做了一些奇怪的动画片，拿给马特·赖伊斯看。就是这个让他说，
oh, I think, I think I want to sign you. And back then he was like, You're talking about sketch cartoons, like New Yorker cartoons. Yeah, basically. Well, it was, it was called 101 things to definitely not do if you want to get a chick. And it's just a bunch of dumb.
哦，我想，我想签下你。当时他说的是，你在说那种单幅漫画，就像《纽约客》那种。对，差不多吧。好吧，当时它叫“如果你想泡妞绝对不能做的101件事”。这只是一堆蠢事。
I'd like to see that. Like do not kill their pets. Right. Do not, you know. It's a good, by the way, it's a great note. One to live by. It's just a bunch of really weird stuff. And it was, you know,
这倒是个好建议，顺便说一句。一条生活的准则。那只是一堆非常奇怪的东西。而且它是，（笑）
so anyway, this thing got me my first couple of jobs, this, this packet of sketches. And so right as I was, I had just made my way through the grounding system, got my first job at the Jenny McCarthy sketch show. That was on MTV. And then went to Letterman from that. Oh, I'm so sorry about.
所以不管怎样，这个东西让我得到了前几份工作，这个小品剧本包。就在我刚完成接地剧团的培训，在MTV的《珍妮·麦卡锡小品秀》获得第一份工作的时候。然后从那儿去了莱特曼。噢，我真为……
No, I love her. This is what eight and a half month old kids do. Yeah. You're just, you know what you are? You're just a pacifier away from peace. Just their plugs, little, little corks. I'm so sorry. Okay.
不，我爱她。八个半月大的孩子就是这样的。是的。你知道你是什么吗？你离平静只差一个安抚奶嘴。它们只是塞子，小小的软木塞。非常抱歉。好吧。
Don't ever apologize, Will. So sorry. Not for that. Apologize for a lot of other stuff. No, that little asshole needs to. Hang on, Will. Jesus. Jesus, Will, but your mic is still on.
永远不要道歉，威尔。非常抱歉。不用为这个道歉。为其他很多事情道歉吧。不，那个小混蛋需要。等等，威尔。天哪。天哪，威尔，但你的麦克风还开着呢。
No, I know. She needs, she's, we put headphones on her so she could listen. Oh, she's listening to the podcast. She's a quack. She's got notes. So went to Letterman from there and this was working my way.
不，我知道。她需要，我们给她戴上了耳机，这样她就能听了。哦，她在听播客。她是个小怪咖。她有意见要发表。所以从那儿去了莱特曼，这就是我一步步奋斗的过程。
How was Letterman? I mean, was that a, was that a dream come true? It was a dream come true. It was also, it was my second job. This is, I was terrified of, I did not do as good a job. I thought it was going to be a match made in heaven because this is like, he's my all time,
莱特曼的节目怎么样？我的意思是，那是一个梦想成真吗？那是个梦想成真。而且它也是，那是我的第二份工作。这是，我当时吓坏了，我表现得没有那么好。我以为那将是天作之合，因为这是像，他是我的偶像，
one of my all time comedy heroes. He's, you know. Same, same, same. And just grew up, he was part of the formation of my sensibilities, you know? Just dash of this, dash of that. What was a writing process like on that show? Was it basically writing monologues
我历来最崇拜的喜剧英雄之一。他，你知道的。一样，一样，一样。而且从小到大，他是我审美形成的一部分，你知道吗？加一点这个，加一点那个。那个节目的写作过程是怎样的？基本上是写独白，
or coming up with top 10 things? No, at the time, there was a guy, Bill Schaft was writing the monologue stuff and we would do top 10 lists. We'd do viewer mail. We'd do sketches. So everything that was comedy stuff besides the monologues was the writers.
还是想出前十名榜单？不，当时有一个叫比尔·沙夫特（Bill Schaft）的人在写独白的内容，我们会做前十名榜单。我们会做观众来信。我们会做小品。所以除了独白之外的所有喜剧内容都是由编剧们负责的。
And there was a team of, I don't know, 12 or 14 or something like that. And you sit around a table every day or was it once a week or, you know what I mean? You would never sit around a table. You would write stuff in your office and then you'd turn it into, you know, some thing on a door.
当时有一个团队，大概有12到14个人左右。你们每天都围坐在桌子旁开会，还是每周一次，你懂我的意思吗？你们从来不会围坐在一张桌子旁。你在办公室里写东西，然后你把它交到，你知道的，门上的某个东西里。
Oh, really? And then, yeah, it was an interesting system. You mean like one of those little folder catchers like on the outside of a doctor door, you just drop your ideas and come on. Exactly, that's exactly it. And you wouldn't work with the other writers? Sometimes you would.
哦，真的吗？然后，是的，那是一个有趣的系统。你是说就像医生门外的那种小文件夹收纳袋，你只要把你的想法投进去然后走人？没错，完全就是这样。你不会和其他编剧一起工作吗？有时会。
Sometimes you'd go in and write. I have a lot of guys I still am friends with. Rodney Rothman was writing there when I was there. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Carter and Craig. I don't know if you know those guys. They were good friends. Everyone was really...
有时你会进去一起写。我有很多到现在还是朋友的人。罗德尼·罗斯曼（Rodney Rothman）在我那儿的时候也在那儿写东西。噢，是的，是的，是的。卡特和克雷格。我不知道你们认不认识那几个人。他们都是好朋友。每个人都真的……
Did Glaser write a letter before Conan or no? I don't think so. Glaser, though, he was on the Jenny McCarthy sketch show. Oh, he was? John Glaser. I think that was his second show he had worked on. John Glaser, one of the all time funniest dudes. Yeah.
格雷泽在柯南之前给莱特曼写过信吗？我不这么认为。不过格雷泽，他曾在《珍妮·麦卡锡小品秀》工作过。噢，是吗？约翰·格雷泽。我想那是他参与的第二档节目。约翰·格雷泽，史上最搞笑的家伙之一。是的。
Will, do you miss Saturday Night Live? Do you miss the camaraderie, the writing of the sketches, the being in the sketches, the schedule like... Snacks. Every week. The schedule, no. I miss all the people, but they become like a family. So you still keep in touch with everybody.
威尔，你怀念《周六夜现场》吗？你怀念那种情谊，写小品的经历，在小品里表演，还有那种日程安排——零食。每周都是如此。日程安排，不。我怀念所有的人，但他们已经变得像家人一样了。所以你仍然和每个人保持联系。
But do you miss being on the show and getting your ideas out in that way? I was always nervous about the show. Yes, I do miss the show, but I also there's not really a part of me that wishes I was still there. Too much anxiety. It's just very stressful and I watched Fred.
但你怀念留在节目中并以这种方式表达你的想法吗？我一直对这个节目感到紧张。是的，我确实怀念这个节目，但同时我内心并没有任何部分希望自己还待在那里。焦虑太多了。压力实在太大了，我看着弗莱德。
I came in the year with the Fred came in too. Fred Armisen, listener. Fred Armisen and he just had such a joy to perform and wasn't nervous at all. And I was just shitting my pants all the time. I was terrified. It got better over the years, but it still was something that was just always terrifying
我和弗莱德是同一年进剧组的。弗莱德·阿米森（Fred Armisen），听众朋友们。弗莱德·阿米森，他表演时充满了快乐，一点也不紧张。而我总是吓得屁滚尿流。我当时吓坏了。虽然这些年有所好转，但那对来说我依然是一直感到恐惧的事情。
for me. You were always very fastidious about it too. Like you were, when you were in the, I remember pre-show, you would always be going over your shit, whatever. You'd always be like really in it. Like you didn't, not to say that you weren't loose, but you were, you, it was important to you to do it well and do it right.
你对这方面也一直很挑剔。就像你在，我记得演出前，你总是会反复琢磨你的段子之类的。你总是非常投入其中。就像你并不——并不是说你不放松，但你，对你来说，把它做好、做对是很重要的。
Like you wrote, you're very meticulous in that way. I mean, that is a compliment, by the way. Well, it's, that can be a really good thing and a really bad thing. And, you know, sometimes it would be great because sometimes that level of preparation and trying to hit stuff in a certain way really works. And then sometimes you're just too tight.
就像你写的，你在那方面非常一丝不苟。我的意思是，这是一个夸奖，顺便说一下。嗯，这既可以是一件非常好的事，也可以是一件非常糟糕的事。而且，你知道的，有时这会很棒，因为那种准备程度和试图以某种特定方式呈现效果的水平真的很管用。但有时你又太紧绷了。
And it just kind of... Seems like there's always a good balance between cast members that take it very, very loosely. Like in other words, kind of smiling all the way through it, almost laughing all the way through it. And then other ones that are, they're almost off book. They don't even need the cue cards. They're so well rehearsed and serious about it.
然后它就会有点……看起来总是在那些表现得非常非常轻松的演员之间保持着一种很好的平衡。换句话说，他们几乎是一路笑着完成的，甚至是一路大笑着完成的。然后还有另一些人，他们几乎脱离了剧本。他们根本不需要 cue 卡（提词卡），他们排练得太充分、对此太严肃了。
It's a sort of a great little cocktail. But bottom line, the experience of a lifetime, it's what an honor to be there, but I'm happy to watch it as a viewer now. Cause I get stressed even when I watch it as a viewer. I go, ugh. How weird is it now though, all these years later, and you start writing this, you know,
这真是一个美妙的小鸡尾酒组合。但总而言之，这是一生难得的经历，能在那里是一种多么大的荣誉，但我现在很高兴作为观众观看它。因为我甚至在作为观众观看时都会感到压力。我会想，呃。然而所有这些年过去了，现在感觉有多怪异，你开始写这个，你知道的，
you start this character, you and Solomon write this character, McGroober, the sketch. So funny. That is super, I know. There's not enough room for the applause. And you start this character, this running bit, which is so great.
你创造了这个角色，你和索洛蒙创造了这个角色——麦格鲁伯（MacGruber），那个小品。太搞笑了。超级搞笑，我知道。掌声的声音都快装不下了。你创造了这个角色，这个持续的梗，真的很棒。
I love the way that the bit is always a runner in the show. So it's always a series of like three or four little minute long things, right? And you do that over the course of a number of years, then you make the movie. And then now years later, you guys have just made the series, McGroober. Is it weird to think like, we just wrote that as a bit.
我喜欢这个梗在节目中一直是一个贯穿始终的连环梗。所以它总是一系列持续三四分钟的小短片，对吧？你在几年时间里不断地做这个，然后你拍了电影。然后现在多年以后，你们刚刚把这个系列拍成了电视剧，麦格鲁伯。回想起来会不会觉得很怪异，我们会想：我们当时只是把那当成一个小笑点来写。
And we're doing it now as 2021. Very weird. When we first did it, I thought the first one was like, it was fun and fine, but I don't think any of us ever thought this will be anything more than just a one-off little short that we do. I was kind of surprised that the audience
而我们现在在2021年把它做成了剧。非常怪异。我们第一次做的时候，我以为第一期挺好玩也挺不错的，但我想我们谁也没想到这会变成比我们做的一个一次性小短片更大的东西。我有点惊讶观众们
seemed to respond to it. I was like, oh, you like this, huh? Well, MacGyver was a very big hit at the time that you guys launched that. Can I ask an in the weeds question? It was, is the McGroober and the whole thing, is it close enough creatively for you guys to have to cut in the McGyver people
似乎对此有所回应。当时我就想，哦，你喜欢这个，是吧？好吧，在你们推出那个节目的时候，百战天龙是非常轰动的。我能问一个比较冷门的问题吗？就是，马格鲁伯和整个这件事，在创意上有没有足够接近，以至于你们不得不跟百战天龙的人
on rights and licensing and all that stuff? Or did you get enough separation where you don't have to worry about that? That was something that was... Parity, right? Tough during the movie because we're trying to, I think there was a cease and desist letter and then we had to make sure to go in and...
在版权、许可和所有这些事情上进行交涉？还是说你们拉开了足够大的差距，所以不用担心这些？那是……差不多吧？电影拍摄期间挺艰难的，因为我们在努力，我记得好像有一封停止侵权信，然后我们必须确保去……
That means you're doing it right, by the way. I mean, at the end of the day, with the movie stuff, especially, there was not a ton of crossover between what McGroober does and what McGyver did. It was a jumping off point and then it kind of... The sketches, definitely, yes. But then once the movie version of it
顺便说一句，那意味着你们做对了。我的意思是，归根结底，尤其是电影方面，马格鲁伯所做的和百战天龙所做的之间并没有太多的重合。它只是一个切入点，然后它有点……小品里肯定是的。但一旦电影版
is so different than the sketches, there's like a whole different mythology. So the good thing about, we just got a chance to do it as a series and we're just finishing editing it right now. But early on, when we were trying to do this, the McGyver people gave us their blessing and so that was an awesome thing.
和那些小品大相径庭，就好像有了一套完全不同的神话体系。所以好在，我们刚刚有机会把它做成剧集，现在我们刚好完成了剪辑。但在早期，当我们试图做这件事的时候，百战天龙的人给予了我们他们的祝福，所以那是一件非常棒的事。
That was just like a green light and we didn't have to worry about it. One of my favorite movie, quite literally, cinema scenes of all time. Can I guess what it is? And it's so forte, it's beyond belief. Yeah, go ahead and guess. Is it when he pulls his pants down
那就好像开绿灯了一样，我们根本不用担心它。我最喜欢的电影，简直可以说是所有电影中我最喜欢的场景之一。我能猜到是什么吗？而且它太有特色了，简直难以置信。行，你猜猜看。是不是当他脱下裤子
in front of Ryan Phillips, crying? No, that was so funny. Sean, get up and huddle into the other room. Take your chair away from the table. Okay, okay. Breathe through your nose. Sean, I like that scene too. I think it makes me laugh, so all right.
在瑞安·菲利普面前哭泣的时候？不，那个太搞笑了。肖恩，站起来，去隔壁房间挤一挤。把你的椅子从桌子旁拿开。好吧，好吧。用鼻子呼吸。肖恩，我也喜欢那个场景。我觉得它让我大笑，所以好吧。
No, it's when the guy tells him off and Forte's like, fuck you. And he takes it and he goes, whatever, like 4-H-C-X-Y-Z, 4-H-Z. And it's the license plate of the guy who's told him off. And he keeps repeating it, right? And he's like 4-H-Z and he keeps saying it. And then way later,
不，是那个家伙数落他，然后福特说，操你的。他记下了，然后他说，随便吧，比如4-H-C-X-Y-Z，4-H-Z。那是数落他的那个家伙的车牌号。他一直在重复，对吧？然后他就说4-H-Z，一直说个不停。然后过了很久，
Ryan Phillips is going through McGyver's stuff and he finds this notebook and he opens it up and it's page after page of just the license plate. And then killing the guy and blowing the guy up. Page after page after page of his fucking license. That is hilarious. I still have that. That's one of the things, that notebook,
瑞安·菲利普翻找百战天龙的东西，他发现了这个笔记本，翻开一看，一页又一页全都是那个车牌号。然后是杀了那个家伙，把那个家伙炸死。一页又一页全都是他妈的车牌号。太搞笑了。我到现在还留着。那是其中一样东西，那个笔记本，
it's a KFBR 392, I have that notebook and then the Miata. We bought the Miata for like a thousand bucks from the production. Did you really still have it? You still have it? Yeah. Okay. Do you drive it?
就是那个KFBR 392，我有那个笔记本，还有那辆马自达。我们从剧组花了一千块钱左右买下了那辆马自达。你真的还留着它？你还留着它？对。好吧。你开吗？
Yeah. Never drove it once. And then they had to tow it out of my garage to use it for the series. Oh, that's fantastic. That's great that you kept it. Oh my gosh. Oh yeah, yeah.
开。一次都没开过。然后他们不得不把它从我的车库里拖出去，给剧集拍摄使用。哦，太棒了。你能留着它真是太好了。哦天哪。哦对，对。
Wow. Now, Will, let me ask you something about writing because, you know, one of my favorite TV shows of all time is Last Man on Earth. I've seen every episode and when it came out, I was like, ah, finally like a show that is, you know, because it's been a while, I've been like a dry spell since a really great comedy
哇。威尔，现在我要问你一个关于写作的问题，因为你知道，我最喜欢的有史以来最好的电视剧之一就是《最后一个男人》。我看过每一集，当它刚播出时，我就想，啊，终于有一部这样的节目了，你知道的，因为已经有一段时间了，自从一部真正伟大的喜剧
came along and it was so funny. It was just so interesting and different and hilarious and laugh out loud and funny. And did you have, and I know you wrote it and you started it and you directed a lot of them or all of them? I don't know. Is there- I didn't direct any of them because I was too busy writing
出现以来，我经历了一段荒漠期，而且它太搞笑了。它就是那么有趣、与众不同、令人捧腹大笑。你当时，我知道是你写的，你发起的，而且你导演了其中的很多集或者全部？我不知道。有没有——我一集都没导演，因为我太忙于写作
and doing all the other stuff. So we had a bunch of wonderful directors. Okay. And so do you, isn't that just all consuming and overwhelming and would you do it again? Or is there a part of you that's just like, you know what? It's so fun to just show up and act and somebody else is-
和处理所有其他事情了。所以我们有一群非常棒的导演。好吧。那么你，难道那不是让人全神贯注且压力山大的吗，你还会再做一次吗？还是说你心里有一部分会觉得，你知道吗？只管出现去演戏，然后别人来——
Oh wait, is your daughter fighting a bobcat? Oh, here she is. Oh, here she comes. The little angel. Oh, look, it's a baby. Listener, we have a very beautiful baby here. Looks like most babies accept the added beauty. Oh, my God. Look at that.
哦等等，你女儿在和山猫打架吗？哦，她在这儿。哦，她来了。小天使。哦，看，是个婴儿。听众朋友们，我们这里有一个非常漂亮的婴儿。看起来大部分婴儿都在原有的美貌上更上一层楼。哦，天哪。看那个。
She's playing with the microphone. Will, she's incredible. I'm gonna say something to Zoe. Hey, Zoe, what do we have for breakfast this morning? Okay, listen, she knows a cue when she hears one. Exchange numbers with Bateman and he'll send her some tips like on how to like lose water weight or whatever, like all the good, you know, important.
她在玩麦克风。威尔，她太不可思议了。我要跟佐伊说句话。嘿，佐伊，我们今天早上吃什么早餐？好吧，听着，她听到暗号就知道该怎么做。和贝特曼交换号码，他会发给她一些秘诀，比如怎么减掉水肿或者别的什么，总之都是所有那些好的、重要的。
Oh, she's really, really cute. Well, she is absolutely gorgeous. Yeah, she's so cute. Look at that. Sean, this is a great opportunity for us to talk about where we're at with adoption conversations with you and Scott. Go ahead.
哦，她真的，真的很可爱。嗯，她简直太好看了。对，她太可爱了。看那个。肖恩，对我们来说，这是一个极好的机会，可以讨论一下你和斯科特关于收养的谈话进展到哪一步了。请吧。
Yeah, I had a long question, but let's skip that. I'll answer your question after this. Okay, my motto is I'd rather regret not having them than have them regret it later. I'd rather regret not having them. Well, it's a great sound bite. I mean, look, we're not looking to write something like above the wall, you know, at the door
对，我本来有个很长的问题，但我们跳过那个吧。我稍后回答你的问题。好吧，我的座右铭是，比起以后后悔没生，我宁愿后悔生了。我宁愿后悔没生。好吧，这真是一句绝佳的引语。听着，我们可不是在找那种写在墙上的东西，你知道的，贴在
at a football locker room. You know, we're not looking for new Rockney words. We slap on the way out to the pitch. Hey, look at, remember Sean said this? Yeah. All right, at the end of 2021. It's a war cry. Oh yeah, sorry, I know your death date.
橄榄球更衣室门口。你知道的，我们可不是在找什么新的罗克尼名言。我们在冲向球场时顺便说出来的。嘿，看，还记得肖恩说过这个吗？对。好吧，在2021年底。这是一个战斗口号。哦，对，抱歉，我知道你的死期。
Sorry, I should have mentioned it. I know your death date. I fucking, I should have. Oh my God, you know what? I had, there was a guy in high school, he took a lot of acid at this high school I went to. It was not a real academic tower, but yeah, this guy took a lot of acid
抱歉，我本该提一下的。我知道你的死期。我他妈的，我真应该说的。天哪，你知道吗？我有一个，我上高中时有个家伙，他嗑了很多迷幻药，就在我上的那所高中。那不是什么正经的学术殿堂，但对，这家伙嗑了很多迷幻药，
and the kids we were in class with, he said, no, this guy, his gift, he can tell you your death date. He can close his eyes and he can tell you how and where you're gonna die. No kidding. You know, he's just a 10th grader like the rest of us. And so, yeah, one lunch or nutrition or whatever,
跟我们同班的一个孩子说，不，这家伙，他有天赋，他能告诉你你的死期。他能闭上眼睛，告诉你你将怎么死、在哪里死。真的吗？你知道的，他也就是个像我们一样的十年级学生。所以，对，有一次吃午饭还是营养餐什么的，
I asked him, he said, he said, I got you in a hotel room surrounded by a bunch of bottles, middle age. That's awful. Yeah, and then he just turned around and kept walking. And I'll just never, you can't unhear that, right? You can discount it, but you can't unhear it. And so you've spent your life trying to avoid that.
我问了他，他说，他说，我看到你在一间酒店房间里，周围摆着一堆瓶子，人到中年。太可怕了。对，然后他转过身就继续往前走了。我永远，你听到了就忘不掉了，对吧？你可以不把它当回事，但你忘不了。所以你这一生都在极力避免那种事。
Well, yeah, that was probably had something to do with my decision to go ahead and stop the drinking. Sure, and you remembered it because it was so fucking traumatizing. Well, yeah, you can't forget stuff like that. By the way, I did a Ouija board thing in high school, just messing around. And it told me when I was gonna die,
嗯，对，这可能跟我决定戒酒有点关系。当然，而且你记得它是因为它太他妈的创伤了。嗯，对，那种事你忘不掉。顺便说一句，我上高中时玩过一次通灵板，就是瞎闹着玩。它告诉我我什么时候会死，
it said that I'm gonna die when I'm 73 by getting stabbed. Oh my God, yeah. Wait, so you are gonna end up having some enemies. Yes. You don't have any now, but I don't know. Kind of fun. Or maybe it's a good friend. But see, like you're never gonna be able to forget that.
它说我会在73岁时被人刺死。哦天哪，对。等等，所以你最后会有一些敌人。是的。你现在没有，但我不知道。挺有意思的。或者也许是个好朋友。但你看，你永远也忘不了那个。
When you turn 73, when you wake up that first morning 73, you're gonna say to yourself, well, now I got 12 months to watch my back. I gotta watch my back this year. Oh yeah, I'm getting a fricking, like a bunker. I'm just gonna wait out that whole year. Yeah, like a panic room. I always wanted to get a clock
当你满73岁的那天，当你73岁醒来的那个清晨，你会对自己说，好吧，现在我还有12个月来提防着点。我今年得小心防范了。哦对了，我会弄一个他妈的，像掩体一样的东西。我打算把那一整年都熬过去。对，就像安全屋一样。我一直想买个时钟，
that counted backwards from like 80 years old. And it would tell you how many hours, days, minutes, seconds you have left to live. So you've already predetermined that you're gonna take 80 and... Well, you just pick a random, like let's say 80, because maybe your grandfather died when he was 80 or 75 or 95 or whatever it is.
它能从比如80岁开始倒计时。它会告诉你你还剩多少小时、天、分、秒的生命。所以你已经预先决定了你会活到80岁然后……嗯，你只是随便挑一个，比如说80岁，因为也许你爷爷80岁时去世了，或者是75岁、95岁，随便多少岁。
But then you hit start and it counts backwards. Wouldn't that be wild to wake up and say, I only have this many hours left? A lot of anxiety. Well, what's gonna be enough for you? What's your number? Like Forte, what's your number? If you go, if I died this age, I'm fine with it.
但接着你按开始，它就开始倒计时。一醒来就说我只剩下这么多个小时了，这不是很疯狂吗？会有很多焦虑。好吧，对你来说多少才算够？你的数字是多少？就像福特，你的数字是多少？如果你觉得，如果我在这个年纪死，我完全可以接受。
I mean, I think I'd like 80 sounds. Like, you know, not that I don't want to live past 80. 80's young. Yeah, that is young. My dad's 83, Jim Arnett. Yeah. Yeah, for Jim Arnett. Let's hear it for Jim Arnett.
我的意思是，我觉得80岁听起来……就好像，倒不是说我不想活过80岁。80岁还年轻。对，那确实年轻。我爸83岁了，吉姆·阿内特。对。对，为吉姆·阿内特干杯。让我们为吉姆·阿内特欢呼。
For me, it's gonna be 90. Anything over 90 is gonna be bonus, but I really feel like I can make it to 100. I gotta... How is your family history? You got two. So far, so good. Knock wood.
对我来说，大概是90岁吧。90岁以上的一切都是赚到的，但我真的觉得自己能活到100岁。我得……你的家族史怎么样？你有两个。目前为止，一切顺利。敲木头。
Yeah, dad's 85 and like a bowl. Okay, awesome. Mom's doing well too. Okay, Sean. I'm good anywhere between 75 and 80. Sean's dad is 85. Sorry, he's doing 85 on the... The opposite direction of where Sean is.
对，爸爸85岁了，身体像个壮汉。好吧，太棒了。妈妈也很好。好吧，肖恩。我介于75岁到80岁之间都行。肖恩的爸爸85岁了。对不起，他85岁正在……朝着肖恩的反方向。
Yeah. He's doing great. Right. Yeah, three of my grandparents died like 97, 97, 94. And my great-grandmother died at 105. Wow. Yeah. Oh, you're sad.
对。他身体棒极了。没错。对，我的三个祖父母分别活到了97岁、97岁、94岁。我的曾祖母活到了105岁。哇。对。哦，你真伤感。
But see, here's my thing. You can't do the things you want to do after 80. Like you can't... That's not true. That's not true. But I mean like, you know... 83, my dad's very active. He's out.
但听着，我是这么想的。80岁之后你就没法做你想做的事了。比如你不能……才不是那样的。才不是那样的。但我的意思是……83岁，我爸非常活跃。他经常出门。
He goes to the trainer a couple of times a week. He's out cross-country skiing and snowshoeing. And he's in Canada. Oh, right on. He's trying to stay on brand. Oh, is that right? Oh, is that right? Willie, did you see the Leafs last night?
他一周去好几次健身教练那里。他去越野滑雪和穿雪鞋健走。他在加拿大。哦，太棒了。他一直在努力维持人设。哦，是吗？哦，是吗？威利，你看了昨晚枫叶队的比赛吗？
They just can't get the puck out of their own zone. They gotta give her, yeah. Guys, you gotta give her. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. So Forte... Yeah. So...
他们就是没办法把冰球弄出自己的防区。他们得加把劲，对。伙计们，你们得加把劲。我们马上回来。好的，回到节目中。所以福特……对。所以……
Can I get an answer just for my question? Let's double back to your question. So back to that, thank you first of all for the nice things you said about Last Man on Earth. Yeah, I love that show so much. That was a dream scenario of getting to like have your own show and control it. Right.
能回答一下我的问题吗？我们回过头来谈谈你的问题。所以回到那个话题，首先谢谢你对《最后一个男人》的赞美。对，我太喜欢那个节目了。能拥有自己的节目并掌控它，那简直是梦想中的场景。没错。
And it was also... But overwhelming, right? A nightmare in terms of what it did to my physical and mental health. Cause like, just because of my mental makeup, like I'm very OCD, I'm a perfectionist, which would be surprising for people who see how I keep my body
而且它也是……但压力也很大，对吧？从它对我的身心健康的摧毁程度来看，简直是一场噩梦。因为，仅仅因为我的心理结构，比如我有很强的强迫症，我是个完美主义者，这对于那些看到我如何保持体型
and basically everything in my life. That's not true. Nothing is perfect except for my little baby. Will, you look good. You always keep in touch. Yeah, so do you prefer just showing up being an actor instead of all that control? Well, I mean, there's a wonderful part about that.
以及我生活中基本上一切的人来说可能会感到惊讶。才不是呢。除了我的小宝贝，没有什么东西是完美的。威尔，你看起来状态不错。你总是保持联系。对，你也是。所以你更喜欢只管露面当个演员，而不是掌控这一切？嗯，我的意思是，这其中有非常美妙的一部分。
You can just, like if you have a lot of trust in the people who are the directors, then that's the best because you're just coming in, doing a job, you know, have a life outside of it. You don't have to worry about all the post-production and doing sound mixes and everything. It's a tremendous amount of work that goes into this stuff. And if you're somebody who's gotta have his fingerprints
你可以，比如如果你对那些导演非常有信任，那这就是最棒的，因为你只是来上班，做好工作，你知道的，在工作之外有自己的生活。你不必担心所有的后期制作、音响混音以及诸如此类的事情。这其中有大量的工作要做。如果你是一个必须把自己的指纹印在
on every single part of it, cause you're, I don't know, I'd like very specific things. And if you're willing to give up that control and with Last Man on Earth, I was not willing to give it up. And I was like, okay, I entered into this. I'm just gonna wait till it's done. And I would just go nuts.
每一个细枝末节上的人，因为你，我不知道，我喜欢非常具体的事情。如果你愿意放弃这种控制权，而在《最后一个男人》中，我不愿意放弃它。我当时就想，好吧，我既然加入了这个项目。我只想等到它完工。我简直要疯了。
Well, here's Forte's dedication. I remember going to like some award thing or whatever. And you were, it was that part, I think it was maybe season two of Last Man. And you had shaved half your face and half your head. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. Right? Was that season two?
好吧，这就是福特的敬业精神。我记得我去参加过什么颁奖典礼之类的。你当时，那是那个部分，我想大概是《最后一个男人》第二季的时候。你刮掉了半边脸和半边脑袋。哦对，对，对。对吧？那是第二季吗？
Yeah, I had a big long beard. He had a crazy long beard and crazy long hair. And then just everything was shaved on this other half. Completely, including eyebrow, completely shaved on that side of the head. And so from, if you sum from the profile, he looked like you're like, oh, look at Forte. He's like, let his beard go and stuff.
对，我留着一大把长胡子。他留着疯长的长胡子和疯长的长发。然后另一半脸上的所有东西都剃光了。完全剃光，包括眉毛，那一侧的脑袋全剃光了。所以从，如果你从侧面看，他看起来你会觉得，哦，看福特。他就像是，让胡子长出来之类的。
And then he would turn his head and you're like, Jesus, what the, it was incredible. Yeah, it was really cool. So Sudeikis plays my brother on the show and he, long story short, he, as a prank, he shaved off the entire side of my one side of my body and left the other side very hairy. I did that once to a guy.
然后他一转头，你会想，天哪，这他妈的，太不可思议了。对，真的很酷。所以苏戴奇斯在剧中扮演我的兄弟，然后他，长话短说，作为恶作剧，他把我身体一侧的毛发全剃光了，而另一侧留得很浓密。我以前对一个家伙做过那种事。
A guy passed out in my living room, shaved off his eyebrow while he was over. Yeah, he didn't know until he got back to college the next day. Well, it turned out he was dead, right? He never found out. So in the show, I didn't want to get him the satisfaction of knowing that he had burned me very hard.
一个家伙在我客厅喝醉睡着了，在他做客的时候我把他的眉毛剃了。对，他直到第二天回到大学才发现。嗯，结果他死了，对吧？他从来没发现。所以在剧中，我不想让他知道他狠狠地整了我一把而满足。
So I pretended that I really liked it. And I wore it for several episodes, but that meant that I had to frigging wear it in real life, you know, keep that hairstyle in real life for a month. Oh God. That was so crazy. It was. That's so cool though.
所以我假装我真的很喜欢它。我在好几集里都顶着这个发型，但这意味著我必须在现实生活中他妈的顶着它，你知道的，在现实生活中保持那个发型一个月。哦天哪。太疯狂了。确实。不过真的很酷。
It was so crazy. And then so, who do you have now in the new season of McGroober? Who do you have? Because you mentioned, you know, you work with a lot of same people. You got Sudeik as obviously some of you worked with an SNL and he came on Last Man.
太疯狂了。然后，在新一季的《马格鲁伯》里你都有谁？你都有谁？因为你提到过，你知道的，你和很多老熟人合作。你有苏戴奇斯，显然你们有些人在周六夜现场合作过，他也上了《最后一个男人》。
John Solomon has been a collaborator with you for many years on writing stuff. And so, is John's part of this new McGroober series? Yeah, John, Yorma and I are two, three original. Yorma was the one who had the original idea, which we then, the three of us all wrote everything together, me, John and Yorma. And then Yorma directed the movie.
约翰·索洛门多年来一直是你写作方面的合作伙伴。所以，约翰是这个新的《马格鲁伯》系列的一部分吗？对，约翰、约尔马和我，我们是三个元老。约尔马是最初提出这个想法的人，然后我们三个一起写了所有的东西，我、约翰和约尔马。然后约尔马导演了这部电影。
People would know Yorma for just for Tracy in Wisconsin. Yorma is one of the Lonely Island guys and wrote and directed and performed in many sketches, especially, you know, they started those digital shorts at SNL. Yeah, Andy Samberg, they're gonna box the Lonely Island. Yeah, yeah. Chikoni, last name?
人们知道约尔马可能是因为《写不完的剧本》。约尔马是寂寞岛（The Lonely Island）组合的成员之一，在许多小品中担任编剧、导演和表演，特别是，你知道的，他们在周六夜现场开创了那些数字短片。对，安迪·萨姆伯格，他们要跟寂寞岛组队。对，对。奇科尼，姓什么？
Chikoni, yep, yep. Chikoni. Chikoni, like he directed the movie and just did an amazing job directing the movie. And now there are eight episodes for this McGroober series and Yorma directs for, John directs for. John's an amazing director too and directed a bunch of Last Man on Earths
奇科尼，对，对。奇科尼。奇科尼，就像他导演了这部电影，导演工作做得太棒了。现在这个《马格鲁伯》系列有八集，约尔马导演四集，约翰导演四集。约翰也是个出色的导演，导演过好几集《最后一个男人》
and wrote a bunch of them too. He's, he's. John Solomon is a brilliant. Top of the heap. Yeah, a brilliantly funny guy. Both those guys. Where are we gonna see this McGroober show? It's on Peacock.
也写过好几集。他，他。约翰·索洛门是个才华横溢的人。顶尖人物。对，一个才华横溢的搞笑家伙。他们两个都是。我们在哪里能看到这个《马格鲁伯》节目？在Peacock上。
Got it. Peacock. That's great. Wig's back too. Wig is back. Yeah. Wig is so. Kristen Wig.
明白了。Peacock。太棒了。韦格也回来了。韦格回来了。对。韦格太……克里斯汀·韦格。
The three main people, me, me, Kristen Wig, Ryan, Philippi are all back. And then Lawrence Fishburne has a big part in it. And Billy Zane is the bad guy. And Sam Elliott plays my dad. Wow. Oh my God. Yes.
三个主要人物，我，我，克里斯汀·韦格，瑞安·菲利普都回来了。然后劳伦斯·菲什伯恩在里面扮演重要角色。比利·赞恩演反派。萨姆·埃利奥特扮演我爸。哇。哦天哪。是的。
And they're all amazing. Lauren Michael's still collecting a fee for this. Yep. Yes. Oh yeah, yeah. Lauren, it was so fun. Oh, good. He makes this whole thing happen.
而且他们都太棒了。洛恩·迈克尔斯还在为这个收版税吗？对。是的。哦对，对。洛恩，太有意思了。哦，太好了。这一切都是他促成的。
Like, it's people, I mean, as you would imagine, this show just came, or the movie came out and just shit the bed so hard, just incredibly hard. Yeah, and Lawrence basically, what three of the six feathers on the Peacock. I mean, he's, he is Mr. NBC. He's amazing. So he's, you know, his, obviously none of this would be
就像，人们，正如你可以想象的那样，这个节目刚出来，或者说电影刚出来时就彻底搞砸了，简直是一败涂地。对，劳伦斯基本上，可以说是Peacock上的顶梁柱。我的意思是，他是NBC的台柱子。他太棒了。所以，你知道的，显而易见，如果没有他，这一切都不可能
possible without it. I mean, none of my whole career would be possible without him. You know, he's, everything I have, we'll thank him for. Well, he's got good taste. He's always been a champion. You really tickle him, I think.
发生。我的意思是，没有他，我的整个职业生涯都不可能实现。你知道的，我拥有的一切，我们都要感谢他。嗯，他很有品位。他一直是个坚定支持者。我想你真的很讨他喜欢。
He legitimately loves you. I love him. He's wonderful. So it's, you know, yeah. I mean, I hope, I look back, my answer with Saturday Night Live, I hope, I hope, you know, yes, I am happy to be away from the stress of it, but God, what an honor to be a part of that show and so many fun, wonderful people
他名正言顺地爱着你。我也爱他。他太棒了。所以，你知道的，是的。我的意思是，我希望，回首过去，我对周六夜现场的回答是，我希望，你知道的，是的，我很高兴能摆脱那种压力，但天哪，能成为那个节目的一部分是多么大的荣幸，有那么多有趣、美好的人
I'm still friends with. Yeah, I told you earlier, Letterman and SNL, those were like my, those were part of what molded my sensibilities and then to get a chance to work at both of them is, you know, it's a blessing to be able to work at just one of your dream jobs. I got to do two of them. Yeah, not a lot of people can say that.
至今仍是我的朋友。对，我之前跟你说过，大卫·莱特曼和周六夜现场，那些就像是塑造我审美情趣的东西，能有机会在两家都工作过，你知道的，能在一份你梦想的工作里干过就已经是一种恩赐了。我有幸干了两个。对，没几个人能这么说。
What kind of stuff do you want to do now? Now you're on the sort of the tail end. Maybe you'll do more McGroober after this. I'm sure it's going to be amazing. We know that you're going to, that you want to live at least another 30, maybe four years. We never got an actual answer on you, but. Well, I'm 51 now and I have 22 years left to live.
你现在想做什么类型的事情？你现在正处于尾声阶段。也许在这之后你会拍更多的《马格鲁伯》。我确信它会非常棒。我们知道你会，你想要至少再活30年，也许44年。我们从来没有得到你关于年龄的确切回答，不过。嗯，我现在51岁了，我还剩22年可活。
Oh, right, because you're getting stabbed at 73. Right, right, right. So what are you going to do for the next 22 years? When my daughter stabs me. Oh no, you think it's going to be hurt. I think it's going to be Zoe and. I'm kidding. That would be great.
哦，对了，因为你将在73岁时被刺死。对，对，对。那你接下来的22年打算做什么？当我女儿刺死我的时候。哦不，你觉得会是她。我觉得会是佐伊，还有……开玩笑的。那倒挺棒的。
Let's get another look at her. Let's see if we can see the rage in her eyes. Oh my God, she just came in the room. What do you, but I do want to get back into it. Where do you see yourself? Like what do you, what do you want to do? Do you want to write more movies for yourself? Do you want to do sketches?
让我们再看她一眼。看看我们能不能在她眼中看到怒火。哦天哪，她刚走进房间。你，但我确实想重操旧业。你觉得自己将来会怎样？比如你，你想做什么？你想为自己写更多的电影吗？你想做小品吗？
Such a weird time in showbiz, right? I mean, do you want to. I'll tell you it like it's, as I said, it's all gravy. After, if I could have stopped after SNL, you know, everything after SNL was gravy, then I mean, getting to do that movie Nebraska, who I would have never thought I'd get a chance to do something like that.
演艺圈现在真是个奇怪的时期，对吧？我的意思是，你想……我告诉你，这就好像，正如我所说的那样，一切都是意外之喜。之后，如果我在周六夜现场之后就收手，你知道的，周六夜现场之后的一切都是意外之喜，然后我的意思是，能去拍那部电影《内布拉斯加》，我以前从没想过自己能有机会做那种事。
You want to do more stuff like that? Oh, sure. I mean, I'd love to, I'd love to do everything, but the main thing, I just want to be in a situation where I can spend a lot of time with her growing up. And so, you know. And do something. Yeah, where you can be around.
你想做更多类似的事情吗？哦，当然。我的意思是，我很想，我很想做所有事情，但最主要的是，我只想处于这样一种境况：我可以花很多时间陪伴她成长。所以，你知道的。做点事情。对，能陪伴在她身边。
No family's important to you. Cause you're very close. Cause I know you're really close to your mom and your dad. Oh my God. Your mom. That is okay. So let's talk about your mom. I love your mom.
不，家庭对你很重要。因为你们很亲密。因为我知道你和你的妈妈爸爸非常亲近。天哪。你妈妈。没关系。那我们来谈谈你妈妈吧。我有个主意。
First of all, I have an idea. But by the way, about, well, go ahead and tell everybody about my mom, then I can tell you my idea. Yeah, Will, let's hear about his mom. Well, his mom's incredible, Patty. She's one of the nicest people ever. She's got a lot of ideas, right, Will? Yep.
首先，我有个主意。但顺便问一下，关于，嗯，先跟每个人讲讲我妈妈的事，然后我再告诉你我的主意。好的，威尔，让我们听听他妈妈的事。嗯，他妈妈是个不可思议的人，帕蒂。她是有史以来最好的人之一。她有很多点子，对吧，威尔？对。
She's got a lot of ideas. Is Patty with an I or Patty with a Y? With an I. Thank you for asking. And she's such a sweet, you know, open, kind, warm, loving person. And you guys are really, really close, which I love about, one of the things I love about you
她有很多点子。帕蒂的帕是带I的帕还是带Y的帕？带I的。谢谢你发问。她是一个如此甜美、你知道的、思想开放、善良、热情、充满爱心的人。你们真的，真的很亲密，我喜欢的一点，我喜欢你的一点
instantly is how close you are with your family and close you are and good you are to your mom and she to you. And it's just a great example of, and she's, you know, she knows that she's such a big part of your life and everybody who knows you and who's friends with you knows your mom. Oh yeah. And it's really awesome.
就是你和你的家人有多亲近，你和你的妈妈有多亲近，你对她有多好，她对你有多好。这真是一个很好的榜样，而且她，你知道的，她知道自己在你的生活里占据着如此重要的地位，每个认识你、了解你的人都知道你的妈妈。哦，对。这真的很棒。
And she's the best. I mean, she's just a magical woman. She is, if you are somebody who doesn't love, not just like, but love my mom, there's something wrong with you. I agree. You're just somebody, I don't wanna be around. She's an absolute delight.
而且她是最棒的。我的意思是，她简直是个神奇的女人。她，如果你是一个不爱，不仅是喜欢，而是爱我妈妈的人，那你肯定有什么毛病。我同意。你这种人，我可不想跟她待在一起。她绝对是个开心果。
I've always loved your mom. But she, so yeah, she does have a bunch of, what I would say are very shitty ideas, just a bunch of shitty comedy ideas. And so she would always, when I was at SNL, she'd always say, oh, I have, Carol and I were talking and I have a great idea for this. And then just say this pretty bad idea.
我一直都很爱你的妈妈。但她，所以是的，她确实有很多，以我来看非常糟糕的点子，就是一堆糟糕的喜剧点子。所以每当我还在周六夜现场时，她总是会说，哦，我有，卡罗尔和我一直在聊天，我对这个有个好主意。然后就会说出这个相当糟糕的点子。
And I'd say, mom, okay, mom, save that for the Patty Forte sketch show. So eventually I was like, that didn't happen enough times. And I'm like, I gotta do a Patty Forte sketch show. So the, as soon as time kind of opens up, we're gonna do a thing, which is basically it's a show which will follow her making her own sketch show.
而我会说，妈妈，好吧，妈妈，把那个留给《帕蒂·福特小品秀》吧。所以最终我想，这发生的次数还不够多。我心想，我得搞个《帕蒂·福特小品秀》。所以，一等时间稍微空闲下来，我们就要做一个项目，基本上这是一个将追踪她制作自己的小品秀过程的节目。
I mean, that is such a good idea. She will write everything. She will make every decision. And so all kind of be in there, just like guiding her along the way, like, well, I don't think that's a great idea. But if you wanna do it, and she and her friend, Carol are going to write all the,
我的意思是，这主意太棒了。她将编写所有内容。她将做出每一个决定。所以大家都会参与其中，就像是一路引导着她，比如，嗯，我觉得那不是个好主意。但如果你想这么做的话，然后她和她的朋友卡罗尔将编写所有的……
and she's 70, she's about to be 78. And Carol, I think is 80 or 81. And they're gonna fricking. You're anticipating this huge comedic train wreck and that that will be the fun of watching the slow-moving collision with God. It's gonna be... That's Zoe looking at daily.
而且她已经70岁了，她快要78岁了。而卡罗尔我想是80岁或81岁。她们要他妈的……你预料到这是一场巨大的喜剧列车失事，而观看这场缓慢移动的相撞会是其中的乐趣，天哪。这将会……那是佐伊在看日常生活。
It's just gonna be so amazing. Cause it would be, you know, you'll kind of follow the process and then the very end of each show will be the actual sketch that she's created. That's actually a really funny idea. It's gonna be, it's incredible. I remember you told me about that a while ago in my, you asked if I, and I said yes.
这将会太棒了。因为这将是，你知道的，你会跟着了解整个制作过程，然后每个节目的最后都会播出她创作的实际小品。这真的是个非常搞笑的点子。这将会，太不可思议了。我记得你前阵子跟我提过这个，在我的节目里，你问我是不是，我说好。
And I'm still, yes. Oh yeah. So each week will also like, it will, that sketch will include, you know, some kind of comedy heavyweight, you know, then I've asked Will to be in them. Oh my God. In addition to a comedy heavyweight.
而且我依然，好。哦，对。所以每周也会像，那个小品会包含，你知道的，某种喜剧重量级人物，然后我已经邀请了威尔加入。哦天哪。除了喜剧重量级人物之外。
Jason, Sean, if you guys would ever, it will make it very easy for you. Just a couple of hours pop in, be in a sketch with Patty Forte and Carol. Anything you want. You're busy. Wait, Jason, are you saying you're very busy? No, I think Sean was gonna say anything you want. Anything you want.
杰森，肖恩，如果你们俩也愿意的话，这会对你们非常简单。只需抽空花几个小时过来，和帕蒂·福特和卡罗尔一起客串一个小品。随便你们想怎么样。你们很忙。等等，杰森，你是说你很忙吗？不，我想肖恩会说随便什么都行。随便什么都行。
I'm with, I'm with Arnett. My three rules are where do you want me to stand? What do you want me to say? And what do you want me to wear? Okay, we'll get to that later. Well, I mean, I don't know. Patty, Patty will tell you. Where do you want me to stand?
我和阿内特站在一起。我的三条规则是：你想让我站在哪里？你想让我说什么？你想让我穿什么？好吧，我们稍后再谈。我的意思是，我不知道。帕蒂，帕蒂会告诉你的。你想让我站在哪里？
What is it, Sean? Where do you want me to stand? What do you want me to say? What do you want me to wear? And I'd rather regret not, and this is in addition, how long is this quote of yours? I'd rather regret not having where you want me to stand
是什么来着，肖恩？你想让我站在哪里？你想让我说什么？你想让我穿什么？而且我宁愿后悔没有……而且除此之外，你这句名言有多长？我宁愿后悔没有……你想让我站在哪里，
than to never regret not what do you want me to wear. That's exactly right. That's in five, four, three. Three, two, one. Five, six, seven. All right. Ta-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da. Forte, let me just say, again,
也绝不后悔没有……你想让我穿什么。完全正确。倒计时五，四，三。三，二，一。五，六，七。好了。嗒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒哒。福特，我必须说，
you're one of my favorite people. You're so delightful. Every time I see you, I see, if you text or you call, it just, even when I don't talk to you, it just gets that feeling like, oh, yeah, will Forte. I'm so happy you're in the world. I feel that way about you guys. I was very excited to come on here
你真的是我最喜欢的人之一。你太可爱了。每次我看到你，看到，如果你发短信或打电话，它就会，甚至当我不跟你说话时，它也会带来那种感觉，哦，对，威尔·福特。我很高兴这个世界上有你。我对你们也有这种感觉。我当时非常兴奋能来这里，
because each of you individually are so wonderful. And to have you in this unit is just like, it's almost too much for your eyes and ears to handle. Thank God we're not in the same room together. No, I know, it would be too electric. It would be far too electric. Yeah. I loved seeing you and hearing you, talking to you.
因为你们每个人都那么棒。能把你们组合在一起，简直让你的眼睛和耳朵应接不暇。谢天不谢地，我们没有共处一室。不，我知道，那太触电了。会过于触电的。对。很高兴见到你、听到你的声音，跟你聊天。
Will, it's been very, very too long. Yes. Yeah, well, hopefully, I'm in Atlanta right now, but when I get back to Los Angeles, maybe we can all together and hang out. I want to give you the opportunity, Forte, to say goodbye to each one of us individually. Go ahead.
威尔，真的太久太久没见了。对。是的，好吧，希望如此，我现在在阿特兰大，但当我回到洛杉矶时，也许我们能聚在一起玩玩。我想给你个机会，福特，跟我们每个人分别道别。请吧。
Go ahead. Me first. Jason. Hi. It has been very nice talking to you. I appreciate the nice things that you've said to me. And I'm sorry that I could not have been a better guest for you today.
请吧。我先来。杰森。嗨。跟你聊天非常愉快。我很感激你对我说过的那些好话。我很抱歉今天没能成为一个更好的嘉宾。
Well, I'm so glad that you came and appreciate it. This is now, and I will improve. I will take steps to improve for the next time I'm on if I am ever given the chance. Okay. I love you. Say hello to Amanda for me. Will do.
噢，我很高兴你能来，非常感谢。现在是这样，我会改进的。如果我还有机会的话，下次来的时候我会采取措施加以改进。好的。我爱你。代我向阿曼达问好。一定。
And and your girls. And then Sean. Yeah. My husband's name is Scotty. If you want to just. Scotty, beam me up, right? Wonderful. Wonderful.
还有你的女孩们。然后是肖恩。对。我丈夫叫斯科蒂。如果你只想……斯科蒂，把我传送上去，对吧？太棒了。太棒了。
Really, thank you. And that's it. I love you and you're wonderful. And I do, I do would love for you to meet Zoe at some. I want all of you to meet Zoe. Thank you. And please come over, meet Zoe. And I'm telling you, it's pretty awesome.
真的，谢谢你。就这样。我爱你，你太棒了。而且我是说，我真的很想让你在某时见见佐伊。我想让你们所有人都见见佐伊。谢谢。请过来见见佐伊。我告诉你，这真的挺棒的。
Let Jason talk you into it. It's the best. But if you make the decision not to, you're wonderful. Thank you. Well, thank you. I feel the same about you. And it's the right decision. Whatever you do.
让杰森说服你吧。这是最棒的。但如果你决定不来，你也很棒。谢谢。好吧，谢谢。我对你也有同感。这是正确的决定。无论你做什么。
Lovely. Will, Will, we've, of all three of us, we've spent the most time together. You're like a brother. You just mentioned our net's name and Zoe goes off again. I think that we, this is what we've identified the problem. Yeah. She wishes I was there.
太可爱了。威尔，威尔，我们三个当中，我们在一起的时间最多。你就像个兄弟。你刚提到阿内特的名字，佐伊又闹腾起来了。我想我们，这就是我们发现的问题。对。她希望我也在那儿。
Yeah. Go ahead. Sorry, Forte. No, it's just, it's, you know, in the same, the same thing you just said about me, which is very touching, I feel the same way about, about you. So, so I love you.
对。说吧。抱歉，福特。不，这只是，你知道的，你刚才对我说的那番话，非常感人，我对你也是这种感觉。所以，所以我爱你。
You will always be a brother to me. I love you too. And I want to see you more often. Same here. Same here. So thank you for letting me be a part of this podcast. Thanks for being here, Will. And today I feel smart more.
你永远都是我的兄弟。我也爱你。而且我想更经常见到你。我也是。我也是。所以谢谢你让我成为这个播客的一部分。谢谢你来到这里，威尔。今天我觉得自己更聪明了。
Nice. Oh, that's nice. I love that. After this experience. Smart more. Thank you, Will. You're such a delight. Such a delight.
不错。哦，真好。我喜欢这样。经历过这次之后。更聪明了。谢谢你，威尔。你真是个开心果。真是个开心果。
Will Forte, thanks for your time. Thanks for your love. We love you. Love you, pal. Have a great day and love to Zoey and everybody. Thank you. Love you guys. Thanks, Forte.
威尔·福特，谢谢你的时间。谢谢你的爱。我们爱你。爱你，老兄。祝你有美好的一天，代我向佐伊和所有人问好。谢谢。爱你们，伙计们。谢谢你，福特。
Bye, Forte. Bye. Bye, William. Boy, another world-class prick. I mean, right? Could you just feel the anger and the hostility? Not one nice thing out of his mouth. Forte is, he really is.
再见，福特。再见。再见，威廉。天哪，又是一个世界级的混蛋。我是说，对吧？难道你感受不到那种愤怒和敌意吗？他嘴里吐不出一句好话。福特真的是，
He's one of those people, I hope you guys feel the same way that when you see him, you light up. Because he lights up, he just exudes positive energy. He's... Can't see him in a bad mood. No. Armistice in the same way.
他是那种人，我希望你们也有同感，每当你看到他，你就会眼前一亮。因为他光芒四射，他散发着积极的能量。他……看不到他心情不好。不。阿米斯蒂斯也是这样。
It's amazing that those two are... They were a little bit of a duo on the show. Would you agree? Yeah. Kindred spirits. Kindred spirits, different, but came in... I've seen him the same time. Yeah, they were very kindred spirits.
令人惊奇的是，这两个人……他们在节目中有点像是个双人组。你同意吗？对。志趣相投的灵魂。志趣相投的灵魂，虽然不同，但走到了一起……我同一时期看到过他。对，他们非常志趣相投。
I didn't know he wrote on all those things. Like that blew my mind. I was like, wow, I find that fascinating when people have this history of being in the business before you get to know them as a fan, you know? Like he wrote on all of those TV shows, not just that 70s show, but so many other TV shows. When we did the Brother Salmon,
我不知道他在所有这些节目里都担任过编剧。这太让我震惊了。我当时就想，哇，当人们在你作为粉丝认识他们之前就在这个行业里有着这样的资历时，我发现这太迷人了，你知道吗？就像他在所有那些电视剧里写过剧本，不仅是《那 seventies 秀》，还有那么多其他的电视剧。当我们制作《萨尔蒙兄弟》时，
that was produced by our friend, Tom Warner, great guy. And I know, Tom Warner, really old Tom. Tom had hired obviously Will to write on 70s show. So he was his boss there. And then years later, now here is starring in a film that Tom is producing. And I think, you know, it was like a very strange, like he wasn't known as that guy.
那是我们的朋友汤姆·华纳制作的，一个非常棒的家伙。我知道，汤姆·华纳，老汤姆。汤姆显然雇过威尔在《那 seventies 秀》里写剧本。所以他当时是他的老板。然后多年后，现在他在这里主演一部汤姆制作的电影。我想，你知道的，这感觉非常奇怪，就像他以前不以那种身份出名一样。
And all of a sudden, now he's doing this thing. Yeah, very cool. I know, so delightful to have people like that on. This is where Sean's brain goes to buy right now. I know. He's already... He starts to formulate. Three, two...
而突然之间，现在他正在做这件事。对，非常酷。我知道，有这样的人来做客真是太令人愉快了。这就是肖恩的大脑现在开始开动的地方。我知道。他已经开始……开始构思了。三，二……
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, you don't have to... My... You know, you don't have to just... My... He's still, well, we've done take a big bite out of the apple. We've done that, we've done a Biden thing. Yeah. Did you see the way Zoe almost bite it?
不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，你不用……我的……你知道，你不用只……我的……他还在，好吧，我们咬了一口大苹果。我们做过那个，我们做过拜登的桥段。对。你看到佐伊刚才差点咬到
The microphone, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Here's the problem, because I noticed, I don't know about your guys, but I wear my glasses whenever I can, but then I have to, the reading glasses, take them on and off. And I went, what I really need are a pair of... It's going, bye, Bocco!
麦克风了吗？不，不，不，不，不，不。问题在这儿，因为我注意到，我不知道你们怎么样，但只要有可能我就会戴着眼镜，但然后我不得不把老花镜戴上又摘下。然后我想，我真正需要的是一副……拜拜，巴科！
Bye, Bocco! It's the best one ever, aren't it? Woo! Smart. Lass. Lass. Smart. Lass.
拜拜，巴科！有史以来最棒的一个，对吧，阿内特？呜！SmartLass。
SmartLass is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbaco. Smart. Lass. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music,
SmartLass 由迈克尔·格兰特·泰瑞、罗伯·阿尔杰夫和贝内特·巴巴科 100% 有机手工匠心制作。SmartLass。我们的下一期节目将在一个星期后发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，
or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者通过订阅苹果播客或 Wondry App 提前收听无广告版。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。